على مختلف الجبهات يستمر القتال بين
القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه على اراضي
الاخيره شرقا وجنوبا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلنت اليوم عن احباط هجوم اوكراني في
جنوب دونات قتل خلاله 40 جنديا اوكرانيا
كما كشفت الوزاره عن تنفيذ ضربات جديده ضد
مواقع اوكرانيه في كل من حركات ومحور
كوبيان اضافه لاستهداف انظمه اطلاق صواريخ
جراده في مدينه اليمانا من جانبه قال
الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه نفذت
60 هجوما في لوجان
خلال 24 ساعه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
حذرت من ان روسيا تحشد قواتها في لوغانس
بكثافه وتستعد لمهام قتاليه واشارت الى ان
خطر الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه على البنيه
التحتيه لا يزال قائمه على الناحيه الاخرى
اكدت سلطات دوناتس المواليه لروسيا ان
اوكرانيا استهدفت المقاطعه بمئه وثمانين
قذيفه وصاروخا خلال 24 ساعه كما اتهمت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا دوناتس القوات
الاوكرانيه بقصف مركز على المدينه ب 20
صاروره جراند
[موسيقى]